the actors Robbie and stephen amell you
know their work from in Stephens case
obviously most recently arrow which is
in its eighth and final season currently
on the CW and also Robbie who has played
the flash and now they are both in a
film called code 8 that is in theaters
and on demand next Friday where they are
playing a couple of guys with
supernatural abilities in a crazy-ass
world good to see you both Stephen and
Robbie Amell together how are you guys
good thanks good man yeah it's good to
see both of you here too okay so uh
where do we start with you guys have you
ever been in a film before is this the
first time you guys ever work together
or what we work together on the flash
but we didn't have any lines together
what do you mean they wrote if we team
up for a fight against one of the big
bads and they were like five different
versions of the script where we said
things to each other and they were just
like you can't talk it's too weird
you people know you're related yeah what
about a line that I just look at him I
go you look familiar
there's something like that I did we
should have been fun we should have
asked to ad-lib one take they would have
kept it yeah yeah I mean seriously I
mean what do you what are they gonna do
fire you on the spot for ad-libbing a
line actually done you couldn't have
pulled the Do You Know Who I am sort of
hard very much like that so who how are
you you were later your cousin's who's
the who's the relating dads or brothers
your dad's our brothers yeah okay and
you grew up in in Toronto yeah no we
spent a lot of time together as as kids
I'm seven years older than Robbie and
and then we reconnected kind of in our
I'm me and my late 20s and him in his
early 20s worried when we got here okay
now are you are you Raptors fans are you
what are what how would you describe
your what are what your allegiance
sports-wise
yeah I love the Raptors I grew up a
Leafs fan because our grandfather was on
the board of directors at Maple Leaf
Gardens ok a lot of games but the Leafs
were really bad for a long time and
didn't really do anything about it ok
and we moved to LA and now you're go
Kings go well we got season tickets
right or a fraction of what it would
have cost it you can't get them in
Toronto
and now they won the cup and we want to
win two cups with a lot of Canadians on
the team so are you taking credit for
the Los Angeles Kings championship run
yes well we stopped getting season seats
after 2014 so so now look at them now
for me I was in the house for Game six
Raptors warriors in Oakland and there's
a photo of me sitting on the ground
outside Oracle Arena crying and I'm
flying to Toronto for one day next week
to watch them give Kawhi his ring so yes
you are a Raptors fan out there crying
huh well I was overwhelmed I know but
you were there right I was there about
eight rows above the Raptors bench okay
yeah
so where are you on the pecking order
with Drake in terms of celebrity
ambassador celebrity rather celebrities
yes celebrity Raptors fans Stephen where
are you I don't I'm not entirely sure
yeah be up there Mike Myers is that a
lot of games is it okay I don't know
what because I don't live in Toronto I
don't know where my pecking order is I
feel like I'm a lot higher in terms of
rams fans that I'm given credit for ah
this is Danny Trejo all the time okay
well he's he's legitimate I mean I think
he was oh my but he was here I think
when you know like Deacon Jones was here
right and like I think he's got a little
bit more Los Angeles right guys I got
season seats when when they came back
and my wife and I are I've been to see
them in Seattle this year we were in
Arizona last weekend and we're going to
Dallas and we went to New Orleans twice
last year we were there for the NFC
chancy you were there for that what was
that like to be were you wearing like
Rams gear in the bill oh yes what was
that people in New Orleans is my second
favorite city in the United States after
LA and they're so lovely and because of
where I was I was right behind the Rams
bench I was completely unaware of what
happened Wow
what are you talking about they didn't
show the they didn't show the replay in
the stadium I couldn't see because I was
so low right and it was on the other
side of the field towards the towards
the Saints bench on the sidelines like I
didn't know what happened so I was
gleeful you were just totally oblivious
when it came down to it and walking
the building they were still they were
still like cool yeah we had it we had a
seat saved at a bar filled with saints
fans and we watched the AFC Championship
game and then they showed the highlights
from the NFC Championship game yeah and
I got a little worried no I actually
asked for security to walk into the
washroom what I had to go so because you
didn't have your bow and arrow on you to
take care of business yourself stephen
and robbie amell here on the Rich Eisen
show and then I'm doing NFL gameday
morning um two weeks later at the Super
Bowl and on occasion I'll just look down
at my my Twitter feed to see what people
are talking about and all of a sudden my
Twitter feed is lit up because the best
I could tell is somebody was talking
about how handsome I was in person and
it's Stephen Amell with his 2.4 maybe a
little bit less than back then maybe
like only 2 points some odd million
Twitter followers saying it's weird at
Rich Eisen is way more handsome in
person and I'm just wondering what's so
weird about that Stephen nothing's weird
about it it's both 3 hours before game
time you get to the Super Bowl early
yeah it's like boarding an international
flight and and I was down at the at the
mercedes-benz Stadium they have I wasn't
on the field level but they have this
club where you cut where you're
basically you know there's a you don't
field passes but you're on third level
yeah and I just thought it would be a
funny thing to tweet because I'd had a
few beers
and and then I went back to and the one
went back to my Twitter feed and I'm
looking down and I looked up and you
were 2 feet in front of my face because
I looked around and I'm like that's ok I
see Stephen and then I saw your wife
with you as well and no offense but I
would have been much better if your wife
was the one who had tweeted that out
couldn't agree more
ok you know what I mean so not that
there's anything wrong with that
whatsoever but yeah
that's an end that's how you and I got
to you were Pleasant we had a nice we
had a nice chat we did I only treat the
truth and I by the way I appreciate the
herbs
sir number of CW Twitter followers that
started tweeting at me that normally
might not have on a Super Sunday sorry
no no it's great it's fine I've got a
large tent I'm willing to bring anybody
in there and so you know and then I saw
you in the green room I said you know we
good to meet you Robby and we have met
before we had actually met before today
you're saying yeah you um seed a golf
tournament at Lakeside Golf Club we play
in the in the Los Angeles Red Cross yes
okay and then you presented me with a
long drive a golf club glove did I give
you a club look yeah okay
yeah did you win the long drive I did
you've got that game a much better
golfer than I am football all right now
let's get into this what's the name of
this film that suddenly went viral on
Twitter a few months ago wrong no it's
myself it's called the Duff and it's a
teen comedy and the guy who posted it
had no business watching ABC Family when
it was on when we shot the movie mm-hmm
I fought really hard we got the set and
there was a big giant diffusion setup
yes it right where I'm supposed to
explain what a diffusion is divisionism
we're shooting in Atlanta it's the
middle of the summer and the Sun is
beating down on you yes
so the cinematographer sets of a giant
diffusion which is like the screen right
a giant white screen right to keep the
to keep this right so I get to my mark
and right where I'm supposed to throw a
football is a giant diffusion so I'm
like where am I supposed to throw this
football and they're like we'll just
throw it to somebody standing beside the
camera I'm like so I'm throwing the
football to someone three feet in front
of me right and this is just a PA who's
standing beside the the camera and I
don't want a rifle of football at
somebody a few feet from me with desires
and equipment all around well I just
said I'm making this stupid dim like
dinky don't pass throw emojis
I fought the director on it you fought
it you fought the director yeah I was
like just make some space for me they're
like we don't have time for this which
is true it's a five week shoot it's my
first lead role in a movie I don't have
any real power
hmm when that went viral the director
texted me and he's like I'm so sorry
what happened and he was like I can go
on Twitter I'm like don't it's fine I'm
like just hopefully it'll die one day
and then it went way more viral and I
had friends hitting me up and they're
like what's wrong with you I'm like shut
up this is not my fault now I got in
touch with them immediately and he said
I have been dreading this day Samir it
was like six years ago I'm like great I
went to the premiere I saw it and I was
like oh my god this is going it's gonna
happen right away and in like of all the
reviews I only saw one where someone
called it out and social media wasn't
like that big wit and I was like okay
I'm clear and then this happened and my
poor wife my blood was like boiling for
two days does your competitor robbie
amell run well I just I grew up playing
sports I grew up playing really
competitive hockey I played high school
football but it's not nearly as big in
Canada mm-hmm but I'm the guy who hates
seeing poor athleticism on camera mm-hmm
because I didn't grow up an actor and it
just always really bugs me and I was
like this is my nightmare being the guy
that I hate so but there was a really
you couldn't sign arm it you couldn't
because it I couldn't really do anything
honestly paint the football it and posts
and or tell the or tell them well or say
no or tell them hey just change the line
so that I'm about to throw and then my
co-star says something and I pull it
back but sometimes you can't do that cuz
when we discussed it the next day and
everybody Robby was all over you of
course the point where you dragged your
wife or wife's pregnant right yeah so
she couldn't catch the football so a
friend of mine who's in our fantasy
football league he texted me I might
come over please I'm like I just need
you to catch a football in the street
and he's like you're gonna throw I'm
like I just I'm like look my throw is
not perfect but it's a hell of a lot
better than what's on on screen so your
wife is shooting this video so you could
show that you can actually throw it yeah
he dropped a few passes that was like
take four for Chad
the next day I came on this yes you came
to my defense yes because I had a
similar situation you don't wash your
hands when you pee well I was doing a
SportsCenter commercial with Stuart
Scott who's washing his hands at the
men's room yeah you hear a flush I come
out of a stall you hear a flush a jockey
walks out of the stall you hear a flush
and then the horse walks behind Stuart
who makes kind of this look like that
strange and just continues washing his
hands and I said I'm into this except
for the fact I have to wash my hands
walking I don't have time it'll kill the
comedic timing all of that yeah and the
the sound guy seeing me bang the
directors and the associate directors
and everybody doesn't matter it doesn't
base it that sound you'll notice he says
to me it's more important don't worry
that you wash your hands before you go
in there and I'm like that doesn't
matter you can see the screen grab up
there the way I handled it is I walked
out of the stall with my hands in my
pockets to make it seem like you know I
didn't use anything in there and I don't
have to wash my hands you kept your
hands in your pockets the whole time oh
you're hiding I wasn't thinking clearly
Stephen I was just beside myself and
unlike you Robbie where you knew it was
kind of like a sleeper cell for seven
years and now me it was just like a week
until I wound up in like Yankee Stadium
for the World Series and somebody
screamed out yo eyes and why don't you
wash your hands when you go to the can
and I was so pissed off and there was no
Twitter there was anything I couldn't I
you know I couldn't take to the streets
to show off how I can wash my hands the
funniest are people on Twitter that like
that are like I don't care if I was
throwing the football
I'd have set it up in a way where I
could really throw the ball and I'm like
that's fine but you've never been on a
movie set like a day on a movie set
costs hundreds of thousands of dollars
you need to try and push production by
an hour good luck
I direct message the the segment to you
Steve and I'm like you got to help you
you did that's how I found out about I
don't think you did I think you piled on
in a way Robby's very athletic for an
actor I was like thanks I guess I've got
I've got a couple of sleeper cells out
there don't you worry that Robby's an
excellent athlete for an actor boy you
just kept shoveling dirt yep there you
go I appreciate your help though
well you're showing off some great
abilities and some great supernatural
abilities in côté tell me all about this
movie Robbie go for it what do you got
takes place in a world where four
percent of people have this these
abnormal abilities but you know they're
marginalized for them most live under
the poverty line and in our world than
many you know outnumber the few and and
for that reason they're kind of held
back suppressed
the police force is very militarized and
at its core our movies really about how
far someone will go to save a loved one
which is what we think kind of everyone
could relate to yeah I mean and we shot
I mean we shot this back in 2000 and 16
2015 well we shot short film turned it
into the feature we shot the feature
over the last two summers right and it's
it's it's very strange because the
movies the movie hits on a lot of tones
that are very prevalent in you know
discussion nowadays and the most cool
thing about it for us is it started out
as an idea and then we tried to do some
crowdfunding and wanted to raise 200,000
bucks and ended up raising over 2
million and got to make something really
cool with family and friends that's
amazing and it's gonna be again in
theaters and on demand
next Friday one week from today Robbie
plays the role of Connor Reed who has
supernatural abilities is to throw a
football 3,000 yards and Stephen plays
the role of Garrett who throws Conor
under a bus very great supernatural
abilities check it out code 8 it's great
to see you guys four more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel - 39
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app